[Music]
on this wednesday night putting a clamp
on rising coved 19 cases in canada's two
largest provinces more restrictions
in quebec we basically did everything
the government asked us
and we're still shutting down and in
ontario the pressure and the pushback to
close a game
the last straw for single-use plastics
they are harmful in the environment how
ottawa's proposed ban will make
only a small dent plus the blow to
businesses a colossal contributor to
climate change
the harmful effects of fertilizer used
in farming
and facebook finally blocked some
conspiracy theorists
the difficulty in deleting them
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are continuing to watch the spread of
covid19 especially in canada's two
biggest provinces
quebec's premier has asked people to
keep going to work and to school but
otherwise to stay
home new case numbers were below 1 000
in quebec today but
hospitalizations have doubled in two
weeks toronto's public health officer
warns the infection rates in parts of
that city is rising
so fast if restrictions aren't reimposed
including closing restaurants and bars
the way quebec has
infections may not peak until next
spring
the experience from other jurisdictions
is such that the
earlier we intervene the lesser the
impact of covid19 on the health of the
community
and the shorter the duration of the
control measures
but ontario's premier is resisting
closing bars in restaurants
until he has hard evidence they're
spreading the virus
there are some bad actors but we can't
paint them all with a broad brush
and we just can't shut down people's
livelihoods
that quickly with a broad brush it is a
difficult call
weighing when to reimpose tight
restrictions no one likes
against the risk of losing more lives to
this virus
mike armstrong has our top story tonight
this gym has only been reopened for a
couple of months after the first
lockdown but they'll be locking the
doors again as of friday
the newest wave of restrictions hitting
quebec despite
efforts to avoid it we basically did
everything
the government asked us we're still
we're still shutting down the province
is asking quebecers to stay home as much
as possible
and it's cutting most of the reasons
people might want to leave home
in most of the province gyms and
organized sports are being shut down
bars are closed and restaurants are take
out only in quebec
covent 19 outbreaks are spreading and
hospitalizations are growing
one of the latest outbreaks a major
junior hockey team north of montreal it
has
18 confirmed cases and just played a
game on the weekend both teams have now
shut down
one thing distressing to health
officials is that the age group
most at risk is also the fastest growing
seniors 65 and over as a percentage of
all cases
more than doubled in a week in the last
week it was
six percent and now we have an average
of twelve to
eight represent twelve or fifteen
percent now in ontario
another call for the province to close
bars and restaurants
toronto public health officials
wednesday again appealed to the province
to take action
and appealed to the public to think
twice before leaving home
do you really need to do that activity
or is it just something that you want to
do toronto public health says of its
recent outbreaks
44 percent were from restaurants bars
and entertainment venues
the premier says he believes that's bad
actors not following protocols and for
now he doesn't want to close
businesses we have to be very very
careful when we're messing with people's
lives like this
the one appeal that seems to be shared
by every level of government
is for the coming holiday weekend
thanksgiving they say should be shared
only with people from the same household
mike armstrong global news montreal here
are the numbers across the country today
inside the atlantic bubble a concerning
development new brunswick is reporting
17 new cases that's a record for the
province they're all linked to an
outbreak at a long-term care home in
moncton manitoba has 32
new cases today saskatchewan 10 alberta
has 143
and bc 115. france is expected to
announce new restrictions tomorrow after
an alarming record was set today
nearly 19 000 yukovic 19 cases were
reported in france
in 24 hours in paris all bars gyms and
swimming pools have already been closed
and will stay that way until at least
october 20th
only restaurants that observe strict
hygiene rules can stay open
infections in france have increased
rapidly since late august
hospitalizations have reached a
three-month high and as of tuesday
40 percent of intensive care beds in
paris hospitals
were occupied new restrictions are
likely coming to england
too for the second day in a row more
than fourteen thousand new cases of
covid19 were reported in the uk
hospitalization rates and deaths are
also on the rise
and as crystal gomencing reports
scotland's first minister has already
announced tough new restrictions and
closures
of pubs and restaurants no more pints in
central
scotland and if you want to get a drink
anywhere else in the country
it'll have to be on a patio the reason
we're not closing indoor hospitality
completely
is that we know the benefits in terms of
reducing loneliness and isolation of
giving people particularly those who
live alone
somewhere they can meet a friend for a
coffee and a chat
millions of people in the uk are living
with localized restrictions but the
opposition labor party says the
government is failing
cases are still rising in 19 of 20
communities in england
with measures in place if prime minister
can't see and hear local communities
when they say the infection rate has
gone up tenfold under restriction
and he doesn't realize that's a problem
then that is part of the problem
what we are doing is a combination of
national
and local measures which one week mr
speaker he comes to this house
and supports and the next week
mysteriously he decides to whisk
his support away but boris johnson is
also losing support from his own party
members as politicians and the public
grow
frustrated with the rules and those
making them
ireland and brussels are also turning
off the taps
i understand why
but i think it's a bit long for a month
to not have like
alcohol served so it's a bit sad yeah
for students at least scotland's rules
are being imposed
for just 16 days crystal gamson global
news
london a plan to seriously reduce
plastic waste in canada began to take
shape
today the federal government says the
end is coming for these single-use
plastics plastic grocery bags straws
stir sticks six-pack rings for cans plus
cutlery and some food containers
it's part of the government's push to
achieve zero plastic waste by twenty
thirty
michael couture looks at what's in the
plan and what's been left out
the owners of this ottawa cafe pride
themselves on being environmentally
friendly the pandemic paused their
discount program for people who brought
their own cups and dishes and to survive
they had to grow the take-out side of
the business we had to adapt
and therefore increase our amount of
takeout containers
so we use them quite a lot we do try to
stick to recycled materials but
sometimes that's just
not possible and now she's facing the
prospect of a ban
on those lower cost containers as they
try to deal with declining revenues and
increasing costs
due to covid19 you might as well just
shut us down to put it blatantly because
if you're going to give us the demand
that it has to be a recycled material
then you should probably make it more
cost effective for us
environment minister jonathan wilkinson
contends the proposed ban
only affects a small percentage of
plastic products
that can't be recycled adding it's part
of a bigger plan to increase the
country's recycling capacity
canadians throw away more than three
tons of plastic every year
only nine percent of it is recycled to
be honest i mean we are
we are not leading the world in this uh
this is exactly the same kind of
approach that many countries in europe
including the united kingdom
have gone down this path
environmentalists say canada should be
more ambitious than the european union
even though it's considered the gold
standard for recycling
setting low targets does no one any
favors if you're setting a low target
because you think you admit that this
material cannot be collected and it
cannot be recycled
well that's a justification for not
using it the proposed plan comes a day
after alberta unveiled its pro
plastic plan which includes more
manufacturing and making the province
a recycling hub we have to ensure that
it does not interfere with our ability
to grow the economy
the federal environment minister said
the two plans dovetail perfectly because
it will increase our recycling capacity
adding
plastics will always be part of the
economy the goal is to keep them
out of the environment donna
all right mike lucatour in ottawa thank
you alberta's government is beginning to
set its sights beyond oil
and one thing it's looking at is
hydrogen as a zero emission fuel source
hydrogen when consumed in a fuel cell
produces only water
it can be produced from a variety of
resources including natural gas which
alberta has an abundance of
alberta's premier wants the province to
become a major exporter of hydrogen by
2040.
though as heather urex west explains
there are obstacles
to the plans it's been two months since
larry shock
lost his job in oil and gas the
economy's just got so bad and my
boss shut his company down in
end of august so now uh yeah i've been
fighting looking for new work it's been
a difficult few years for alberta's
energy sector for a number of reasons
but among them global energy markets
that are now
transitioning towards cleaner forms of
fuel as a
clean the cleanest hydrocarbon based
fuel
natural gas as a larger source of world
energy can massively reduce global
greenhouse gas
emissions it's why the province is now
looking to
export hydrogen a zero emission fuel
source that can be extracted from
natural gas
and sold to global markets this is
something that
takes the natural assets that calgary or
alberta excuse me is already rich in
and uses them in a way that is much more
aligned with the energy transition
and what energy demands of tomorrow are
going to be needing
orenstein says there is an emerging
market for hydrogen
as countries around the world work to
lower their greenhouse gas emissions
but if alberta wants to cash in it has a
few obstacles to overcome
including the familiar problem of making
sure there is enough pipeline capacity
to get this natural gas
product to market those problems are not
going to go away
and even if they do go away it's not
going to be a quick turnaround
the technology isn't quite there yet
either i think the big challenge
for us is we do have to crack
the carbon capture nut on a commercial
level we're very very close the utility
company ceo says it will be at least
five years before hydrogen production is
commercially viable
in alberta and for those looking for
work now
that's a long time to wait heather urex
west global news
calgary there is a dire warning tonight
about a greenhouse gas called nitrous
oxide it has hundreds of times more
warming power in the atmosphere than
carbon dioxide
it comes from the nitrogen in
agricultural fertilizer which is used
around the world to increase
crop yields as eric sorensen reports it
makes
limiting global warming in the years
ahead even more difficult
in farming almost as important as
planting seeds are the fertilizers that
help them grow
ian mccreery uses nitrogen fertilizers
from these tanks on his saskatchewan
farm
nitrogen fertilizer is is a really
important crop nutrient to improve our
crop yields
as it is for crops all over the world
but a byproduct
nitrous oxide is a greenhouse gas and a
new report says nitrous oxide emissions
are increasing faster than climate
scientists ever envisioned
for nitrous oxide we're increasing at a
rate that exceeds
the worst case scenario right now which
is pretty devastating
carbon dioxide is responsible for about
three quarters of greenhouse gas
emissions
that's followed by methane and then
comes nitrous oxide contributing about
seven percent
but it packs a punch nitrous oxide
molecules are
up to 300 times more potent than carbon
dioxide when it comes to global warming
more than half of nitrous oxide
emissions are natural coming mostly from
the soil
human-caused nitrous oxide is almost 70
from
agricultural production and overall
nitrous oxide is accumulating in the
atmosphere
at an increasing rate 10 percent greater
than in the 1980s
scientists say nitrous oxide poses a
serious threat to keeping global warming
below
2 degrees celsius agriculture is one
industry that gets climate change
farmers spend their lives watching the
skies they're seeing it in their own
operations that the weather is more
unpredictable more extreme
and more damaging the fertilizer
industry is not disputing the harm
instead developing methods for farmers
to apply fertilizers more efficiently
to reduce runoff and emissions so the
idea is get as much of the fertilizer
into the plant and then limit the
emissions that are problematic for the
environment
in this country critics say ottawa
should do more from independent soil
testing to investments in research and
organic farming if the federal
government wants to be
serious about fighting climate change
they really need to be
putting putting food and agriculture at
the top of the agenda
ian mccreary says he'd like to use
something that doesn't produce nitrous
oxide
but even scientists say that won't be
easy because increasing emissions come
from agriculture
and we can't stop growing food eric
sorensen global news toronto
hurricane delta's path of destruction
coming up what happened when it hit
mexico
this is what it looked like when
hurricane delta made landfall just south
of cancun mexico there are no reports of
injuries but more than 40 000 people had
to seek emergency shelter
delta is now in the gulf of mexico it's
expected to gain strength again before
hitting louisiana
in salt lake city utah the stage is set
for tonight's u.s vice presidential
debate
at the white house president trump who
has covid19 broke
self-isolation rules today and went to
the oval office he also released a video
claiming he is
cured and claiming he has authorized the
use of regeneron a drug he took
that has not been approved for use
except in clinical trials
and on compassionate grounds i think
this was a blessing from god that i
caught it
this was a blessing in disguise i caught
it
i heard about this drug i said let me
take it it was my suggestion i said let
me take it
and it was incredible the way it worked
incredible
he's not a doctor he can't authorize the
use of drugs and there is no cure
as jackson proskow reports president
trump is leaving millions of americans
affected by the pandemic wondering if
they'll get
federal aid stuck in isolation
inside the white house the president
spent the day rage tweeting before
returning to the oval office
despite the risk of infecting west wing
staff he wanted to go to the oval
yesterday
if he decides to go to the oval we've
got safety protocols there
less than four weeks from election day
the pandemic is the defining issue of
the campaign
with case numbers high and millions of
americans unsure of whether they'll get
government support
after trump called off negotiations with
democrats for a bailout
the economy is teetering too little
support would lead to a weak recovery
creating unnecessary hardship for
households and businesses tonight the
virus will be in clear view
as vice presidential candidates mike
pence and kamala harris sit down to
debate from behind plexiglas
having trump out of the hospital doesn't
mean the end
of the discussion about how they've
mishandled the coronavirus
both vp candidates face extra scrutiny
with the current 74-year-old president
sick
and his rival 77-year-old joe biden
on track to be the oldest incoming
president in history if elected
now we have two very senior people
running for
for president and i think there's a real
focus on the vice president
in a way that we've never seen before
pence and harris are vastly different
from the men at the top of the ticket
but are set to tackle the same issues
that defined the first presidential
debate
knowing full well voters may be looking
for reassurance
at a time of unprecedented uncertainty
jackson prosko global news
washington billionaires are not being
hit hard by this pandemic on the
contrary
new research shows the wealth of the
world's billionaires reached a record
10.2
trillion dollars during the height of
this pandemic that's an increase of 27.5
percent from the start of april
tech and healthcare billionaires made
the most money researchers say it's
because they turn to innovation to help
ride this storm
there is now a record number of
billionaires 2 1899.
still ahead facebook cracks down on
conspiracy theorists
you're watching global national
there are all kinds of conspiracy
theories online and now facebook has
finally banned one of them from all its
platforms
q anon believers spread wild theories
based on zero facts
that a group of politicians and a-list
celebrities is running a satanic
baby-eating child sex abuse ring and
plotting to undermine president trump
q anon has moved from the fringes to the
mainstream amplified by facebook which
profited from its extremist views
will today's ban make any difference
that's what jeff semple is looking at
tonight this could be picking up dead
virus
over the course of the pandemic this
montreal man has gone
viral posting videos promoting q anon
conspiracy theories
and receiving hundreds of thousands of
views but his facebook account is now
closed
part of a conspiracy crackdown by the
social media giant
i think it's an important gesture
facebook is now removing any
group or page that openly identifies
with q anon
the group promoting the baseless belief
that a secret cult of celebrities and
government officials
are running a child trafficking ring and
your facts are not fast
q anon claims the same secret cult is
behind the pandemic
part of an attack on donald trump's
presidency i understand they like me
very much
[Music]
which i appreciate the letter q logo has
become a staple at protests against
masks lockdowns and vaccines including
here in canada the pandemic is really
in my view when this thing jumped
borders the man who crashed his pickup
truck through the gates of rideau hall
in july was allegedly inspired by q anon
march especially we noted a
huge uptick in conversation
on mainstream social media platforms
about q anon
a british think tank recently tracked q
anon posts
by country canada is in the top five uh
highest
uh countries the top five countries most
disgusting q
and on online but many of those
discussions and posts are now gone
caught by facebook's q anon purge the
problem
is i think that the narratives have
filtered so
far into not just the far right but into
the mainstream
um that you know it's like putting the
genie back in the bottle
global news found examples of facebook
pages that didn't specifically mention q
anon but promote its imagery and beliefs
and while that montreal conspiracy
theorist's facebook page is down
his youtube site is still up it's just
going to be
it's a game of whack-a-mole you know
they'll be driven off of off of one
social media site and go to another
jeff semple global news toronto
stranded off sea next it takes a village
to move a seal
they're calling him stan and he is the
most expensive dinosaur fossil ever sold
at an auction the winning bidder paid
42.4 million dollars for the nearly
complete t-rex skeleton
quadruple the estimate by christie's
auction house paleontologists worry such
sales will encourage
more private trade of fossils leaving
important specimens off limits
to researchers another massive creature
is the star
of a video that was taken in chile this
two-ton
elephant seal somehow ended up on a
residential street during curfew in a
coastal suburb in chile late
on monday dozens of people mobilized and
helped guide it back to sea
they used black tarps to direct the
steel down the street
clapping and cheering and then it made
its way back to the water
that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the village of westport
in eastern ontario no
no elephant seals there beautiful spot
though please email us
your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye